i'm alex arnold and today i'll be
answering your questions on twitter this
is part two of climbing support
[Music]
first up from jordan harlow how do the
really hardcore rock climbers that go on
multi-day climbs go to the bathroom do
they just go and hope no one down below
gets hit so that is how people did
multi-day climbs in the 60s and 70s way
back in the day people would just go to
the bathroom into like a brown paper bag
and just throw it off the wall that is
incredibly frowned upon now that is
definitely not the way nowadays you pack
everything out so when i go multi-day
wall climbing i typically use my used
water jugs basically you poop into a bag
you bundle up the bag you can like duct
tape it up so it's like a little sealed
bundle and then you can leave it in like
your used water jugs and then seal that
up with tape and then you basically wind
up with sort of jugs of waste dangling
below your actual haul bags as you climb
the wall and then when you get to the
top you just like hike your waist out
and throw it away in a dumpster next
question is from kate warburton who asks
doesn't a bunch of climbers climbing a
mountain mess it up that's a fair
question though it could also be applied
to doane a bunch of hikers going outside
and mess it up or don't a bunch of
fisher people you know overtax the
stream i would say that in terms of
outdoor recreation climbing probably has
a lower impact than many sports
and there just aren't that many climbers
though as climbers we aspire to leave no
trace and to leave things how we find
them so you know not to make a mess not
to disturb anything climbers definitely
aspire to to be good stewards to the
environment aloha hawaii can you find
what's wrong with their repelling
technique seen in a physics textbook
well first off they spelled repelling
wrong so that's what's wrong with the
question second off oh my god i can see
what's wrong with that technique yeah
the first problem is that there's a guy
holding the other guy who's repelling
and this is all very dangerous and
they're both about to die but i do think
that the point of this illustration is
to show the forces and i think their
forces are technically correct but
everything else about the technique is a
death trap
next question comes from zack rudin he
says i need help with my footwork it's
friggin lousy who's got insights here
and this is actually something i could
talk a lot about because i think
footwork is the most important thing in
climbing your hands your arms should be
just maintaining your balance like
keeping you attached to the wall but
your legs are would actually push you up
as you climb the biggest beginner
mistake with footwork is that they place
their whole foot onto a hole the way you
would if you're just like walking in
street shoes they just kind of put the
meat of their foot onto a hold but
really you want to place the tip of your
toe on that hole because that allows you
to be a lot more precise in how you
maneuver your foot afterwards because if
you just put your whole foot flat
against it you can't swivel and like
turn your hip either way afterward
you're just kind of locked into the
position that you put it whereas if you
place the tip of your toe then as you
move higher you can swivel your foot
around as you need to maintain your
balance and next question from jeff
ballard okay about to tackle each of
these a rose move bat hang knee bar and
bicycle who's got tips for jeffrey
jeffrey just listed every sort of trick
move in climbing like every sort of
bizarre
rarely used but very showy and sort of
fun maneuver basically each of these
moves is something you only use when
nothing else works because typically
when you're climbing you can just hold
on to holds and sort of climb normally
the way you imagine climbing where you
like raise your feet and you stand up
and you grab the next hole it's very
rare that you have to use something like
a bicycle which is what it's called when
you push one foot one way and then toe
hook with the other foot so you're
basically applying counter pressure with
one foot pushing and the other foot
pulling to like squeeze the same hold
the only time you really do that is when
you're climbing in really steep caves
and and roofs and things and there
aren't any other footholds to use and
you have to like squeeze the same foot
together a rose move is what it's called
when you take a hold and then you swing
through underneath to the next hold and
it's actually so named from a root in
france called the rose le vampire that a
man chipped he basically artificially
created some pockets that like force
that kind of movement and it like looks
like a circus trick it's pretty cool a
bat hang is when you hang upside down by
your toes if you imagine like a bat
hanging out of a crack a bat hang is a
legitimate way to rest sometimes because
if you find the right little thing to
hook your feet on you can let go with
your hands and rest your hands but it's
rare that you want to dangle upside down
by your toes intentionally knee bars are
probably a more common way to rest when
you're climbing a knee bar is kind of
like a bat hang in that you wedge your
knee against a hold but they're kind of
like bat hangs it's just a way to take
weight off of your hands next question
comes from jamila williams says serious
question what does a professional rock
climber do like they work for a company
or they just compete in competitions
that is a fair question because
professional climbers don't necessarily
do that much no there are many different
paths to being a professional climber
some people do just compete in
competitions and earn money from the
winnings and then sort of support
themselves that way most professional
climbers make a living through sponsors
so they have a contract with say
equipment manufacturers or apparel
manufacturers and then they get paid for
a certain number of appearances a year
so they show up at climbing festivals or
events and they maybe give talks or show
films teach clinics things like that
they write books they write guidebooks
and then a lot of professional climbers
are also just guides so they take people
common next question is from stanky
hazel someone please show me a proper
sloper technique i can't figure it out
the sloper is like a very sloping hole
that's something that you can't just
like hold with your hands it's like
brute hand strength isn't necessarily
enough you need to engage your whole
body to stay tight to the wall and then
mostly you position your body in
different ways to make the hole feel
better for really bad slopers keep your
your center of mass below it like stay
underneath the hold more but i think a
lot of being able to hold onto slopers
has more to do with strength in your
core and your shoulders and sort of like
your whole body if you're reaching to
some hold and it feels terrible you're
like okay that's not a great hold but
then if you shift your whole body to one
side all of a sudden the hold feels a
lot better because you can compress it
between some other hole that you know
you can engage in a different way it's
not always that the the hold is the
problem i mean oftentimes your body
position is the problem next question
comes from laura owen ansi help needed
from the climbing community how should i
improve jumping and dinos it's partly a
question of confidence and partly i'm
just not that bouncy i feel like she
answered her own question if she is
struggling with dynamic movement because
she's not confident and not very bouncy
those are two obvious ways to improve
her her dynamic movement dinos or
dynamic movements big jumps come from
confidence and physical dynamicism like
the bounciness that you have so some of
it is the springiness and like the
amount of power that you can generate
like how much can you actually jump some
of it is the confidence to believe that
you can jump to a hole and actually
catch it and not swing off and hurt
yourself you know i think that
confidence gets developed through
practice you know if you do a bunch of
dinos you're going to have some
confidence that you can't actually do
them and then the bounciness is just a
matter of plyometrics and stuff i can
can you can you jump can you can you
catch things you know how powerful are
you michael torres 45
so rock climbing is harder on my
shoulders than i thought it would be any
suggestions to minimize injuries that's
a good question climbing is relatively
hard on your shoulders or it can be
because it's an overhead sport so you're
like loading your shoulders in a fairly
vulnerable position all the time you can
minimize injuries by focusing on
technique it's you know sort of building
up to it over time you know
strengthening your shoulder joints as
you go try not to like shock load your
shoulder focusing on form like how you
engage your shoulders like keeping your
shoulders down and low not hunching too
much so you don't don't scrunch the
joint and also just maintaining mobility
flexibility like stretching doing
opposition stuff making sure you're all
balanced there's a lot to maintaining
healthy shoulders question from explore
it says climbers what's a good but cheap
entry-level climbing shoe good for all
types of climbing that's actually not
the best question for me because i
haven't used an entry level shoe since i
was about 11 i think well depending on
how serious you are about climbing i
think you outgrow entry level shoes
relatively quickly most entry level
shoes are just cheaper but they're also
typically flatter which makes it more
comfortable on your foot like elite high
performance shoes are often more curved
and hook-shaped more like a talon so
that you can pull with your toe
basically climbing shoes are all built
for specific tasks like they do
different things you know it's like a
different arrow in the quiver it's like
you want the right arrow for the right
task yeah so the shoe i have here is um
this is like a high performance ratio
you see it's ultra soft so you can bend
down it's also sort of naturally
hook-shaped it's downturned it's
asymmetrical where the shoe curves
around to put all the weight on the big
toe this is my go-to gym shoe this is
what i use for climbing indoors and for
for climbing like training on boards
basically this is like a very high
performance sock that puts all of your
weight onto the tip of your big toe
another question from stanky hazel i
just turned 30 and i'm climbing better
than ever but when should i expect to
feel my body slow down i want to age
gracefully on the wall like a mountain
goat not like some old worn out chicken
tumbling down like a fool there's a lot
to unpack in there
it concerns me that they're worried
about aging at 30 because i'm 36 now so
i'm sort of like wow i feel like i'm
climbing better than ever and i'm doing
well so hopefully they can make it at
least six more years before they begin
their steady decline i would say that
climbing has more longevity than most
sports just because it's relatively low
impact on your body so you can be
climbing an elite level into your 40s
50s 60s for example actually in town
here i've been climbing with a professor
who has a full-time job who's climbing
514 so like climbing at an elite level
as a 61 year old ethan whitehill is
bouldering just rock climbing where they
charge you more and give you less safety
equipment that's not far off because if
you go to a bouldering gym in a lot of
cities they do charge you a lot and they
give you nothing but bouldering gyms are
very fun i think he's being facetious
but you know it's kind of clever next
question comes from a do now imagine
later please help should i eat this
20-piece mcnuggets before climbing
stones and josh retreat what are
climber's diets like you should not eat
a 20-piece chick mcnugget before going
climbing in general you shouldn't eat it
at all because it's gross but i would
say most climbers are relatively mindful
of their diet next question comes from
msr gear for mountain climbers what's
your favorite season for climbing and
why almost everybody likes the autumn
you know fall people call it a sentember
or a rocktober things like that
basically uh when conditions start to
get a little bit cooler but it's also
dry nowadays september is kind of too
hot in the western u.s so it's kind of
drifting into november and and december
even but yeah basically the the fall is
is ideal for climbing conditions
pali migo i wonder who first tested
those tents the mountain climbers sleep
in hacked into the side of a mountain a
wager they were insane most of the big
equipment manufacturers were founded by
climbers who were manufacturing the gear
for their own use companies like the
north face and patagonia and mountain
hardwear they were all established by
climbers who were making the gear that
they needed to go on climbing trips i
would say that that they tested their
own gear you know nowadays most of that
gear is tested by athletes so for me as
a north face athlete i get a lot of
prototype north face gear and then use
it in all kinds of crazy places like i
went on climbing exhibition antarctica
where we used a whole new kit of gear
and we're like well we survived
antarctica i guess it works okay it's
probably all right for brooklyn if you
can make it through antarctica next
question is from townswitcher what does
it take to ascend the hardest climb in
the world takes very strong fingers from
jake ireland how does a climber approach
climbing different types of rock kind of
a broad question but i think the simple
way is you just practice on a lot of
different types of rocks so you sport
climb on limestone you climb big walls
on granite and sandstone is sort of like
a fun in between and then of course you
can find all kinds of other sorts of
rock around the world but those are the
the main kinds that you spend most of
your time climbing on the next question
comes from max lotkin a sea of tsars and
he asks where do you see the future of
rock climbing in 2040. it's kind of hard
to imagine because if i think of
climbing in the year 2000 versus where
it is right now it's hard to imagine
what another 20 years we'll do i think
one of the things that i'm interested in
in the sort of future of climbing is in
the next 20 years will equipment
manufacturers sort of upped the level a
little bit so far i don't think there
have been any
big incentives to make cutting edge
futuristic you know ultra light gear
just because there's not that big a
market for it but with climbing in the
olympics now and people competing at a
much higher level i wonder if there will
be more money in the sport like there
will be greater incentives to create
sort of futuristic gear and i think
that'd be pretty cool you know harnesses
that are basically like mesh bags you
know things that are ultra ultra light
those are all the questions hope you
guys learned something until next time